how are you both doing very good thank
you for squeezing me in for the I heard
I have a triple slot now that might not
be true I want to start by saying how
much I love the movie it's just so
fantastic for the two of you though can
you talk about those like first
conversations maybe when you first met
and what that dynamic is you know what I
mean well I mean I'll just say that I'm
very grateful because back in 2000 early
2015 I met with Jim and Washington we
went to NASA headquarters we actually
met at the Air and Space Museum and and
for the following three years he has had
to deal with continuous questioning
pestering he's had to read innumerable
outlines and screenplays and has
faithfully given comments and answers
throughout the process his book is
incredible
more incredible as Jim himself who is
just a wealth of knowledge and has the
pieces that came in in terms of knowing
who to talk to and given how much we
felt the urge to get this right to live
up to Neil standard both on the
technical side and also on the personal
side
I couldn't have done this without
without Jim well
if Josh had been a doctoral student of
mine in space history and I had a number
of them he would have been the best one
I hope my alums you know if they hear it
they hear it could because he was
I mean his work his work he's just I'm
not sure of obsessive as a right word
but he's just dust let any stone go on
turn there's so much he wanted to know
and I think at some point you know not
too far down on the path of our
relationship
he may have surpassed me in terms of
what he knows about the Germany and the
Apollo programs I mean and I and that
really made me so much more confident
about the film and why and the outcome
and then not and also knowing Damien's
Damien's work and in Josh's commitment
to Damien's vision but to have someone
that is so that is so much into the
research side of it and I knew that from
his previous work if I had if I had
worked with the screenwriter who hadn't
done that
then I don't think the results that have
been anything like you know the
magnificence of this film for both of
you I would imagine during the writing
process of both of your materials you've
hit certain bridges they are like how
the f am I going to cross this bridge or
you know what I mean like these
difficult chapters for both of you in
the writing process what were some of
those big hurdles that you felt like
okay how we gotta figure this out well I
can guess on I want him to say but I
think it's at the germinate seams
what you had to do there oh yeah I mean
so one of the hardest things about both
the Gemini and Apollo mission and Apollo
was always going to be a more emotional
mission but Gemini it's just how to
collapse and consolidate and
specifically how to make rendezvous and
docking which you see routinely in space
movies now how does show how challenging
that was how to make sure how to
demonstrate that in a way that is quite
accurate so that was you know in all the
technical stuff understanding it
figuring out how to consolidate condense
you know Gemini transcript is you know
200 300 pages
how am I gonna pulse pull you know make
15 minutes of movie out of 300 pages
even if I choose the most exciting parts
of the Gemini mission
you know the docking and the spin that
still is you know probably a good 200
pages you know what can a load for
Mission Control oh and aunt you wrote
permission yeah and and and so we didn't
have any comms for Mission Control you
know we didn't have that flight director
if I didn't have that transcript so I
really had to go sit down with Jerry
Griffin who had been in Mission Control
and talked through with him you know
literally okay who are the primary
flight controllers they're nine of them
what does each of them say at each of
these five moments that we want to
dramatize let me write that and then
come back to him and go in earlier with
you
very challenging but I actually to me
the one thing I would say I'm sorry I'm
rambling a little bit but this to me is
a very good Jim story it shows how I
think unique our partnership was so
Neela's challenging character as jim
says he's an emotionally tightly
packaged individual how do you get
across what he's feeling on screen you
know even assuming you know you know
Ryan is going to bring so much to it and
convey so much in with so little right
that's one of the things Ryan does so
beautifully we got to the moment where
Ryan hears about where Neil hears about
Apollo on how are we gonna dramatize
that my first pass at that you know we
wanted to have a big emotional moment
and so I literally had Neil slamming the
phone down slamming the phone down on
the receiver and anger and frustration
upset right you know and I sent that off
to Jim and Jim said no way you would
have never done it right and I had to
listen I'd say okay he knows the right
and if he says no way then nobody's
gonna buy it and if nobody buys in this
basically any of them work we're dead
ducks right so what do I do and so I I
said how do I share the pain right in a
way that is contained and so I came up
with this idea of okay what if he's
totally contained here and you're close
in on him and and knowing that Ryan you
know is so talented you could go black
with us out
what if I I stay here and then suddenly
you hear a pop and you look down and
he's been holding a glass that he's been
so trying to contain that he breaks in
his hand and that shows just what he's
feeling and I sent that back to Jim and
I said what do you think and he said hmm
I'm okay with that so that to me that
kind of push and pull with Jim with mark
with Rick you know with all these other
technical advisers that was unbelievable
do you want to say anything about the
writing of the book I mean by the time
Neil gave me the approval which took a
couple of years I was so ready for bear
I mean yeah I don't really remember a
difficult point what the difficulty was
I just I mean I couldn't talk about
anything else I couldn't listen to me
you know dinner it's all I talk to my
family gave me back my mother my wife
gave me this rule that I could only
talked about Neil once per meal and but
she didn't give me a time a time
restriction so you know I just I just
was so consumed with this and I think
Josh probably got that way you have to
script as well you just get so consumed
with it so I mean once I got the
permission to write I don't remember any
particularly you know it's a tough point
where I found it hard to write I was
ready to go sir congratulations thank
you so much for giving me your time
especially since you'd already about to
walk away again thanks you bet
[Music]
[Music]